you have a lot of debt you're
misbehaving with money and then you come
off as prideful and arrogant about how
you can handle your credit cards because
you pay them off every month when 78%
don't and even those that do overspend
especially those of you with airline
miles
it's the biggest scam and freaking
history Americans owe almost a trillion
dollars in credit card debt 78% of you
that use credit cards do not pay it off
every month that means it's only 22% do
when you use a credit card to purchase
something on average
studies have shown several pieces of
research that you spend more money the
average is 12 to 20 percent more that
you spend now depending on the item the
size of the item the process that you're
using you may or may not spend more than
that or less than that an example is
that the average person using a credit
card at a vending machine
spends a hundred and seventy eight
percent more meaning they get a Coke and
a candy bar and a bag of chips where
they were just gonna get a coke when you
use a credit card it reduces the
emotional friction and that's why
everyone wants you to use plastic yes
you do spend more when you use a credit
card it's just a matter of how much more
the larger the item the less the
percentage but it doesn't have to be
much percentage for you to spend more
and those of you that are collecting
airline miles all the studies tell us
the reason they offer the airline miles
all the studies tell us that you are the
worst there's tons of research and the
hilarious thing is is that you are
massively in denial that you really do
believe you're beating them at their
game which is humorous really I mean
it's like you thinking you're gonna come
out playing throw the ball at the
carnival a semi rigged game put the ring
over the hoop put the hoop over the
pylon at the carnival a semi rigged game
you're not going to come out in these
games they know the behaviors it's not a
conspiracy theory
they're just world-class marketers and
spend a bazillion dollar studying your
behaviors you spend more when you get
airline miles because you're so freakin
excited about your free trip to Europe
that's not free because you're so stupid
you believe all that stuff well I don't
agree with Dave Ramsey on the airline
miles it's just because you don't know
the background and the data on this 90%
of airline miles are never redeemed and
of those that are redeemed you have a
substandard experience with the airline
which having a substandard experience
with a substandard industry pretty much
means it sucks I mean think about
airline service other than Southwest is
an oxymoron in it I mean Delta is Greek
for we're not really taking you there we
just said we were its a substandard
experience to start with and then you
get the opportunity to fly through three
extra connections to use your free miles
that was brought to you by overspending
on your credit card and somehow you and
your little brain have figured out that
that makes sense
this is stupid it's stupid even when
you're on a cash basis with a debit card
like I use I don't own a credit card I
haven't in decades but even if you're
using a cash basis like a debit card you
do not feel the pain back in the day
when the dinosaurs roamed the earth and
we put gasoline in our car we used to
have to leave the car walk into the
store and hand the person in the store
money with presidents faces on it when
gas prices went up
we squalled and threw a fit they go from
$2 or $3 to $5 we had a fit people were
acting like the entire world was in
meltdown because when they paid for
their gas with presidents faces they
knew that gas prices had gone up here's
what's interesting when gas prices go up
now you and me we pay at the pump don't
we I pay with a debit card
some of you pay with a credit card and
when gas prices go up you don't think
much about it because it's kind of like
monopoly money
it's a digit you're not even pulling the
receipt off the thing I know because
when I pull up there your stupid receipt
still hang in there so you have no idea
what's your last tank of gas cost you
can't tell me the reason you can't tell
me is it created no pain for you inside
your brain pain is associated with
memory if you create a pain around
something you will have a memory of it
when you know when you buy something
that you saved up for and you pay cash
for it you can tell me to the penny what
you paid for it because it registers in
your psyche the research shows the more
money you make the more credit card debt
you have
because the sloppier you get and the
more you buy into these stupid
rationalizations where you are not
experiencing any emotional friction MIT
did a study that showed that the pain
centers of the brain are activated when
you release cash that is yours to
purchase something when you spend cash
it activates the pain centers of the
brain when you buy the exact same item
with the exact same amount of money with
a credit card nothing happens in the
brain no pain center active okay
activation no brain but no pain center
activation which means you're simply not
registering the spending there's no
emotional friction there's no
intellectual friction nothing is
acknowledged and you spend more you
really do and to argue with that is
ludicrous because that means you have
pride about your level of discipline
which is absolute horse crap I teach
discipline for a living it's what I do I
have taught this for 30 years and I can
fall in this trap of spending more
because I'm using plastic and we're on a
Disney cruise and your room key buys
everything took the grandbabies on the
Disney Cruise right and before I know it
we're just buying Mickey this and Mickey
that and I get the bill at the end of
cruise and I'm going well we got Mickey
Mouse unbelievable man there was no
acknowledgment that this money was
leaving by Papa Dave or by the precious
overspending grandbabies I'll do it
again it's wonderful I can afford it but
when you're broke and you rationalize
you have no net worth your net worth is
$4 and you have no income or limited
income you have a lot of debt you're
misbehaving with money and then you come
off as pride
fall in arrogant about how you can
handle your credit cards because you pay
them off every month when 78% don't and
even those that do overspend especially
those of you with airline miles
it's the biggest scam and freaking
history it's the credit it's the
cigarette of the financial world
it used to be cool and people are gonna
acknowledge that it kills you they're
gonna quit doing it if we have a proven
plan to teach you how to get out of debt
go to Dave Ramsey comm /fp you learn
about Financial Peace University start
your journey to being debt-free no more
credit cards no more debt it's time to
change what you're doing isn't working